[Music]
hello everybody my name is Gila : i'm
engineering director for security and
trust in jesus wheat and with me today
is nico hi I'm Nicolas Bosque I'm
engineering lead for security and Trust
on the G Street and today we'd like we'd
like to talk about email security so
email you know we love it we hate it it
clogs our inboxes it follows us around
on our phones but we can't pass a day
without it you know email has become the
lifeblood of any organization so by
latest estimates there are 3.7 billion
email users and every day there are
around 260 9 billion email messages sent
and received and what made email so
powerful so email is universal it's open
it's fast and it's free
so think about it it's universal
open fast and free that's what makes
email so powerful but it's also what
makes it the most popular attack vector
for cyberattacks which is why we want to
spend the start today discussing email
security so today what we're going to
talk about will discuss some of the
latest threats that we've been observing
related to email security and will tell
you what Google does to protect you
against those threats and then we'll
finish by walking you through some of
the things that you as admin should do
to take advantage of the protections
that we provide so these are the main
email related threat categories that we
discussed today so we're going to talk
about spam
phishing malware impersonation and
interception and we're also going to
discuss email client security and data
loss prevention as it relates to email
and we're going to start with spam which
is the most common one so spam is
unsolicited irrelevant or inappropriate
messages sent over the Internet
to a large number of recipients and we
all know it we all get it we almost
become used to it it's mostly commercial
advertising it's often for dubious
products or all sorts of get-rich-quick
schemes the damage for organization it's
mostly waste of time and for activity
loss but it does add up so over time it
can be significant so what does Google
do to protect you against spam and turn
the stand what Google does we need to
take a step back and look at the
progress of machine learning in Google
across all Google products and services
so today usage of machine learning in
all of Google products has grown
exponentially and specifically the
latest developments in deep learning
enable powerful new capabilities not
possible before that what you see in
this graph is the number of deep
learning projects across all of Google
products so you can see the huge growth
over the last couple of years and the
progress and the shared infrastructure
that we built that powers these
innovations across all of Google make
and they enable us they give us
capability that seem impossible only a
few years ago
just to give you an example from a
familiar product of the kind of magic
the deep learning provides so this is
how Google Photos uses deep learning
models to analyze photos and to Auto tag
them so using machine learning and deep
learning Google photos can analyze the
photos like the one you see on the left
and determine that this photo should be
tagged by the tagged ocean so let's get
back to spam now we take the similar
kind of magic that you see in photo
tagging and apply it to spam detection
so in Google from spam from spam
detection we use what data scientist
called
ensembl ensembl is when you take a
number of machine learning models and
use them and combined to achieve higher
accuracy so what you see in this diagram
is the different models that we use and
the kind of spam detection accuracy we
achieve with that so when you use them
in combination we achieve 99.9 percent
accuracy and we keep improving it so
what does it mean that means that we
have less than 0.1 percent false
negatives this is spam not detecting
ending up in your inboxes and we have
less than 0.05 percent false positive
this is mail by mistake
label the spam and not showing in your
inbox by the way the imbalance that you
see between the two is by design because
false positive are much more disruptive
to business than false negatives so our
models are tuned and optimized to
minimize false positives now let's move
on and talk about phishing
so fishing is an attempt to acquire
confidential information when aspirating
to be a trustworthy person or
organization the damage potential of
fishing is much higher can be both
financial loss of intellectual property
or damage to reputation there's one
especially dangerous variant of fishing
which is spear fishing which is a
targeted message that appears to come
from a trusted person and that broad
cross the person can be your IT admin or
maybe even your CEO let's look at an
example of a phishing attack so a
phishing attack often appears like this
a very innocent looking email message in
this case it's directly directing you to
get some files from Google Drive now
what's interesting is that often the
link the URL and the message it is
designed to appear like a legitimate URL
like from Google you see it says host or
Google Drive dot-com which would make
you believe it's a legitimate Google URL
then it goes on dot service dot fish
something and something so it's just a
random URL designed to look like
something from Google and I'm just
Google as an example it could be your
bank or any other organization that you
trust now if the user clicks that link
that will take you to a malicious clone
of the Google sign-in page and this can
be designed to be a pixel-by-pixel copy
of the real Google sign-in page
if the user unsuspectingly enters their
credential those credentials immediately
go to the attackers the attackers can
then immediately use them to siphon off
sensitive data which can happen in
seconds and when after that happens the
damage is already done so what does
Google do to protect you against
phishing before we go into the specific
mechanisms it's important to understand
that as in many other cases we use a
defense-in-depth
approach meaning we have multiple layers
of defense where we try to detect and
reject any phishing attacks and if they
go and pass through undetected we have
additional layers of protection against
those phishing attack so let's look at
the this is a list of some of the
detection mechanisms that we have so we
have a detection mechanism that combines
both rules written by security analysts
with machine learning models we have a
real-time reputation system which is a
database maintained in real time that
covers domains lengths IP addresses and
the fact that we have in Gmail we have a
user base of over a billion users that
gives us plenty of early signals that
can help us maintain the database
up-to-date in real time and you as
enterprise customers you get the benefit
of that database which is which is you
know uses the the usage pattern we see
from a billion users all of these are
signals used and for the early detection
we also do anomaly detection on the
various entity
is an email message so we look at things
like well what's the to from the the
what's the to feel the from field and
try to find any anomalous patterns which
will again give us a signal of this
might be a phishing attack we also look
for branding personation so brand new
personation would be for example if you
have an email message that contains
let's say the logo of Bank of America
but it's actually not from Bank of
America again that's a strong signal
that this may be a phishing attack so
when we detect a phishing attack we try
to do it as early as possible and reject
it so it doesn't even it doesn't even
get delivered
now what happens and this sometimes does
happen we if we detect a phishing attack
after the message was already delivered
so when when that happens what we do we
go in and reclassified messages that
were already delivered so if there's a
new attack we just found out about it
we're gonna go and see if there's
already if this attack is already
present in messages that we'll deliver
and then we'll go and reclassify it and
it will so it will have the warning that
you see there that's big red warning and
the links and the message itself will be
disabled and by the way this is a key
difference and the kind of protection
that you can get from a filtering
gateway solution and what we at Google
can give you because the filtering
solution has just one chance to protect
you and that's when the email is deliver
to your server after that if something
if they discover something after that
they can no go they cannot go back and
undelivered the message we at Google we
can do it throughout the whole lifecycle
of alpha name
message then we have another last line
of detection which is Safe Browsing so
Safe Browsing is triggered every time
the user clicks a link and then the link
is gonna be checked against the database
of known phishing and Malware URLs and
if it's found to be in the database then
instead of going to that to that webpage
the user is gonna be presented with this
kind of warning telling them that
they're about to do something very risky
and they should not they should not
proceed Safe Browsing is available in
Chrome as well as Firefox and Safari now
so we have all these powerful detection
mechanism but you may still ask and this
is you know this is a great question
well what happens if something manages
to go through undetected through all
those detection mechanism because we
have it's it's an asymmetric warfare the
attacker only has to succeed once to
cause significant damage to the
organization so we may be successful
99.9 % of the times and one attack and
still be a huge damage organization so
we need some last line of defense to
protect against the attack that did go
through and this is your line of defense
the security keys so these are
cryptographically secure second factor
authentication which are not vulnerable
to fishing they're based on industry
standard Fido UTF they support both USB
for use with laptops and desktops as
well as NFC so they can be used with
mobile
Isis and their secure
even if attacker gains access gains the
credential a friend account the attacker
cannot log into that account because
they need physical possession of the
security keys you actually have to touch
physically touch the security key to
gain access these keys are simple to use
and as an organization you can enforce
the usage of the keys through the G
suite admin console in Google everybody
uses security keys you have to have
security keys in order to log into any
Google internal Google corporate asset
and it's it's been working remarkly
built well for us at Google let's move
on to the next threat malware so if
you've been following the trends in
malware for the last 10 or 15 years you
could see a big change from the first
internet scale attacks that we saw in
the early 2000s and the one that we see
today the malware of the early 2000 they
were designed mostly for to cause some
random damage and they were designed
primarily for fast propagation so they
just want to spread as fast as possible
before the antivirus developed
signatures and can detect and block them
the one we're seeing today are very
different they're much more
sophisticated they're financially
motivated so it's typically part of the
crime ring and it can be very profitable
they're targeted there are stealth and
use a number of countermeasures to avoid
detection and now I'm going to ask Nico
to walk us through an example of such
malware that demonstrates all these
recent trends so we are going to go to
their over the case of Loki malware so
starting in February 2016 people started
being targeted by that malware so Loki
is ransomware it uses encryption to
prevent access to fast until ransom is
paid for we estimate that 100 million
people have been targeted but that not
all malware it appeared in multiple
violent and auto released new version to
counter defenses that are in place so
the targeting of victim have been also
evolving over time for instance the
victims of prior data breaches for
instance OPM having liked article a
targeted by that malware after when it
came out run somewhere is really a
booming business with profits in a
millions of dollars so how does a Loki
come up into your inbox it simply
deliver as a simple email attachment
appears here as a simple invoice in the
world document so Loki is using social
engineering to bypass default security
settings and executing macros so with
this very advanced text it's taking
advantage of users so the key lesson
here is your protection is only as
strong as your weakest link and the
weakest link is often the user so even
an attack with a high level of
sophistication need social engineering
here and now Loki is able to run the
next stage of its attack based on
scripting so we're going to go into like
the detail of some of the detail of Loki
so low-key know that modern malware
scanners are using sandbox to monitor
behavior of suspects files so the
sophisticated malware like rocky are
using tracks to detect monitoring inside
the sandbox
so here you can see an example what the
Loki have been doing they are keeping
track of time to detect emulation in the
sandbox so if I start by checking and
checking the time sleeping for some time
and Sun box typically do not really
sleep because people writing Sun box
also very efficient they don't want me
like spinning I'd Leslie and then Loki
is able to compute the time difference
and she got it was running in sandbox
and if it's running in sand wall it will
abort
early and not having either malicious
payload no Loki's also I targeting
specific OSS so you see subtle
difference in script engines to detect a
specific target if not unlike
appropriate target is going to remain
dormant and avoid detection so here you
can see a snippet showing you how Loki
only ones who use Microsoft a script
interpreter not JavaScript it's just
checking for specific syntax that only
work in jscript and uses that to move
along
so once the target has been identified
Loki move the next stage and add really
attacks it's going to download install
and execute the malicious binaries of
course this was like simplification the
actual payload is extremely obfuscated
or to run like a lot of admin services
to disaffiliate all that content so when
the attacks occurred is executed
and sorry all user document we get
strongly encrypted Loki is using like
actually like sick secure encryption to
ensure like all the payload is lockdown
as they run somewhere Loki is supported
by a full ecommerce operation so they
host a Decrypter website on tour but
very resilient and untraceable they also
ask for ransom to be paid in Bitcoin to
be untraceable
so now how we tackling malware in Gmail
so overall we take a funnel approach
starting with blank rejection of common
vectors with like known a high-risk
format what we actually just blanket
blocking at untransferable of gmail we
also have a diversified approach that
uses multiple file scanning technologies
we use like in internal scanner that
will have external AV partners we have
intelligent attachment scanning start
with signature base but for we support
deep scanning for risky attachments I'll
so whisk attachment get deep carrying
which means attachment actually open
inside a sandbox environment and we
monitor malicious behavior to detect
something is a mark and consider that a
piece of software malware without
relying entirely on signature here so we
have a real time good news update on
malicious content we're also doing with
scanning of content at download time so
even at the last moment when you click
download it's actually going to verify
again whether the the definition have
been updated since then finally we also
do link scanning for malware detection
we are going over reviewing list of
links that we know are malicious and we
prevent them to be downloaded so once
again after the differences or the
differences could potentially sell we
still have Safe Browsing
that constantly updates black list of
suspicious sites so same browsing is
taking care of like were left over
malware and phishing but potentially not
was not detected earlier
thanks Nico so we covered so far the
three big threats related to email which
are spam phishing and Malware now let's
move on and talk about impersonation and
interception and before we talk about
this it's important to understand the
root cause that these threats even exist
and the root cause is SMTP so SMTP is
you may know that's the protocol used to
send email across the Internet it's one
of the earliest Internet Protocol and
SMTP stands for Simple Mail transport
protocol and as the name implies it is
simple it was designed for safe and
trusted environment threats were not
taken into account and therefore SMTP
the original SMTP has no security
mechanisms whatsoever which is why we
have to deal with these threats today so
what are they
so impersonation is when an attacker
sends email appearing to be from your
domain or from one or some of your
domain users interception is when an
attacker gains access to email content
in transit typically by some
man-in-the-middle attack which is
important because SMTP traffic typically
travels over multiple hops between
source and destination and I'll let
Nikhil walk us through some of the
mechanism that we have to deal with
interception and impersonation first of
all what we for impersonation prevention
we rely on industry standard but ID
security - on top of SMTP protocol
overstand now are taking advantage of
DNS record with a sunder domain to
publish security settings as they do the
domain
so we have SPF which performing
authentication by specifying what are
the email server to trust dick him doing
notification using cryptographic
signatures and DMACC which established a
policy on how to deal with what
education failures
well first SPF is fairly simple it's
registering the IP address of mail
server but are authorized to send mail
from a domain so here we have an example
of the policy for google.com domain
which lists the known IPS from all our
outbound gateways so we are observed
though several shortcomings with SPF
first invalid because people are putting
in early record in DNS they don't
realize that they don't necessarily pass
correctly and they cannot be part of or
we are unable to make a determination on
what the policy actually mean the record
can also be white listing large IP
ranges and what IP ranges may for
outside the domain or allow undesirable
host to some emails system that are
sharing public IP pools with diff with
different Sanders who are also
vulnerable to that type of issue then
BGP idea hijacking I had enabled
attacker to quickly use white priority
or at least a the IPS to send the
messages and finally DNS record are very
important and they can be hijacked or
the attacker will actually insert them
on either authorized I appear to some
emails so dickham came later and is
referring cryptographic signing of Sant
emails using specific pair domain keys
so this example of message you can see
the dickham header which is configured
to target specific headers inside the
message that gives message ID date
subject from - so was header as well as
the body of the message who are in scope
for hashing so cryptographic hashing is
done that harsh it added as a as part of
the deacon record and that our hash is
signed using this specific domain key
know how is that signature verified when
the email is received the dickham header
includes a selector on which key to
fetch over in dns that key is fetched
and then it is used to verify the
signature so we get like cryptographic
prove that that the contact of the
message hasn't been tampered with
however deacon also hired shortcomings
it provided like strongly proven over
SPF but standa is much more complex
requires cryptography and several
libraries that try to implement the
standard actually hard frozen if they
did not verify everything so it was
actually a abuse wikis like 512 bit RSA
key have been used in a Dicky and
attackers have been able to crack was
key and generate the victim the private
key associated with it and are able to
sign on behalf of the domain so we don't
trust we keep any more private key can
also be stolen from compromised mail
server so misconfigure server that
allows an attacker to breach in the
attacker can steal the the deacon key
and can sign in a because native domain
finally again it's realized on DNS so
hijack dennis rico have been used the
best to insert malicious Deacon Keith
the market offering a policy framework
define the action to take upon failure
of D Keemun SPS without it the
interpretation of the key minus PS is
will left to the recipients mail server
so we another feature of Demark is also
reporting reporting allows aggregate
visibility of Adam to attacker domain so
we see example for google.com record you
can see like the policy set to reject
messages felling the him on SPF it also
sand required required a server to send
an email aggregate email with list of
failures so the recipient of many the
standard domain in destinated is able to
figure out what's happening so we have
taken steps to see phase authentication
status to end-users the goal is really
to raise user awareness of possible
phishing attacks we have fairly clear
visual difference set between the left
side with a note otic authenticated
email that carry the logo for the domain
and the right side which is are not
educated with an appropriate symbol
overall we observe us a really steady
progress to have better in a
notification so not authenticated email
is know at around 1.8 percent in mm late
2016
dawn from 5.8 percent two years ago
develop education we both SPF and deacon
is now at like eighty nine point one
percent up from 80.8% two years ago so
we are really getting to other world
where although toxicated messages are
really associated with something very
malicious
no I would like to go over another
threat again female what is interception
at this point like to give you a quick
primer on 35 year old SMTP protocol
so instead an MTP client basically
connect to a server over TCP and assume
all the email line by line in
traditionally SMTP all that is going
over Claire tags the server and client
just communicate with each other now if
we look at the network perspective for
this the email message is transiting
between Alice server and Bob server over
Internet so I give the opera can
trivially intercept any message it
doesn't have to be activity it's just
passive attacker just listening over the
wire and be able to see the messages
SMTP encryption came at an afterthought
in 1999 and what their father did or as
opportunistic which means it's best
effort it requires both client and
server to support it in this case can
see the beginning of an SMTP production
that superstar TLS and the server
advertise is ability to support our TLS
so the client then establishes a full
TLS connection and inside that TLS
connection that's encrypted the actual
content of the email can be transmitted
securely back to a network perspective
so message is not transmitting over TLS
encrypted channel at the consequent
eavesdropper is enabled to passively
observe the message content so in the
last time in the last year we really
taken to erase and user awareness on the
security of communication of various
parties so we introduced a broken lock
UI
basically simply showing to users
whenever a receive email was received
over a clear text connection rather than
a safe encrypted connection with that
user awareness we've been able to drive
adoption user started to ask senders why
their email we are not encrypted during
their banks I receive an email from my
bank why did not encrypted so because of
they said Gmail we saw incoming email
encryption rate go from the upper 50s to
82% so surfacing encryption status to an
user was enough to put pressure and
drive encryption use a very big win for
the internet because billions more
messages are encrypted every day because
of that padlock the current status
edemen is of course all messages between
Gmail users are encrypted as always but
82% of inbound mail emails from external
sender are encrypted and 88% of outbound
email leaving Gmail service are
encrypted status is not perfect though
email messages can travel multiple hops
between sender and the recipient the
status is only hop-by-hop protection as
a consequence eavesdropper can see
beauty except email if he has an
unencrypted hub so solution for this was
to actually try to protect the message
and from the sender all the way to the
recipient so in January of this year we
added hosted s/mime support inside Gmail
available to G's with enterprise
customers so as mine is an industry
standard for encrypting and signing
messages we've user specific keys as
mine is secure but key management had
traditionally made it very difficult to
implement that carrying organizations so
we've hosted as mimes we bought in Gmail
company's domain administrator can
upload user certificate and just simply
use as mime to cite to sign and encrypt
messages whenever possible and keep is
report so as mine is not just providing
encryption it's also signing each
message with a Sandusky protecting
against impersonation and guaranteeing
message integrity when fraud out
hostilius mime requires no end user
involvement which is a big challenge
with the solution of the past and users
don't have to deal the complexities of
managing certificate and applying the
encryption themselves so now we're going
to go over a different topic which is
Kryon safety Google is constantly
investing in providing you with the
greatest innovation and Gmail clients
are taking advantage of this to provide
you with a safe experience so then email
is based on HTML enabling very rich
content like beautiful image inside
messages however it also introduced risk
so we are now going to dive into some of
the layers of Gmail but may that are
making this safe for users
so HTML in the email messages is coming
from third parties so we do not have
control over those third parties
therefore potentially content can be
potentially broken or contain unsafe
elements as a consequence gmail team is
working on state of the art sanitizer
that fixes HTML and remove unsafe
elements so this example of HTML content
I highlighted some of the content that
needs to be fixed like an example with
margin in the case is invalid
potentially going negative going outside
of a window and enabling clickjacking
with overriding some element of the UI
the ball tag is not balanced which can
allow escaping outside of HTML content
the rest of the message is not balanced
at all the Lister should always be
enclose the link URL should be fully
qualified and go through a redirect or
typically to hide the referee and
finally of course we have a script that
should be removed to provide prevent
kansai scripting again through you know
so after going through sanitization the
HTML document has been fixed and is safe
to display within Gmail clients know for
images starting in 2013 gmail started
proxying all external in the images so
we are doing this to protect you from
Sanders who may try to use images to
compromise the security of your computer
or mobile device so all images in Gmail
are loaded through Google proxy service
they are delivered to clients over HTTPS
only they prevent leaking of IP address
or cookies and they're also prevent
malicious image format so this of course
is just a subset of the security
capabilities we have been able to prou
to use for crimes so so far we talked
about different threats and attacked
vectors that come from outside the
organization and they pose risk to
internal assets but think about the
other way around
email also can can also be used for data
exfiltration so you have you know
everybody has sensitive information
inside the organization email can be
used for that data to leave the
organization and end up in the wrong
hands and that can be either negligent
or malicious so at Google we provide DLP
data loss protections to prevent such
leakage and I'm not gonna go through all
the different options that you have in
setting setting DLP policy there's a
fairly rich set of rules and
capabilities that you can define this is
just one example so here you see
defining a rule the rule is gonna be
applied to all outbound messages
anything that leaves the organisation go
to somebody outside the organization in
this case the rule will be applied to
any message that contains a social
security number and so in the rules that
we offer there's a large number of
predefined matches for sensitive data
such as social security number as well
as the ability to define your own custom
matches for any sensitive data which is
propriety and unique to your
organization as part of the rule you can
also define what we should do when we
have a match so we can either modify the
message reject it or quarantine it
so to summarize so we look today we gave
you a picture of some of the protections
that we build around your usage of email
in Gmail and genji suite and we this is
an area that is very important for us
and we're going to keep invest in that
and improve those those protections but
you have to keep in mind that this is
it's for your domain this is a shared
responsibility
we're gonna keep improving those
protections on mechanism but to really
keep your domain safe you have to take
advantage of them so before we end I
just want to walk through some of the
things some of the actions that we
recommend that you take in order to keep
your domain safe so the first one and is
to use the security keys for
authentication for second factor
authentication and I cannot emphasize
this enough this is your best line of
protections against phishing attack if
you use if you use security keys and and
force that in your organization your
security posture when it comes to
fishing is gonna be an order of
magnitude better next so as Nico
described earlier SMTP is inherently not
a safe protocol so you should set up
dekum and SPF we support both became an
SPF in Gmail and G suite but you have to
set it up so go to your you go to your
admin console make sure that it is set
up
and properly configured and remember
Saudi command SPF is used to
authenticate your email so it tells you
basically tell the world this these are
the server they're allowed to send email
on my behalf and this is how I sign
email messages to authenticate that
these really came from me once you set
up and configure D command SPF the next
step you should go ahead and set up ad
mark policy deem our policy essentially
after you after you did the first step
saying hey world this is how I this is
how I send email the next step is to
tell the world this is what you should
do if you get email that appears to come
from me but it fails those of litigation
mechanisms like the signature doesn't
match up it's not the sir it's not one
of the server that I specified in my SPF
settings what should you do so I can
tell the world if it appears that way
reject it or report to me and this is
the email address so you can tell the
rest of the world how to deal with
something that comes from your domain
and fails those security checks it's a
critical step to make sure that your
domain doesn't become a source of
phishing and spam if any machine by one
of you user gets compromised the next
one is used as mine s mine gives you the
best level of security and encryption
for for email messages that means every
every message is going to be both signed
and encrypted with a user specific key
and it's going to be encrypted through
all the hops it goes between receiving
server by sending server and receiving
server next
set up DLP rules you have it you just
it's there you just have to set it up
every organization has and deals with
some sensitive information that can be
social security number bank routing
numbers license driving numbers whatever
it is make sure if you don't want that
to leave the organization and end up in
the wrong hands do something about it
you can monitor it you can reject it you
can set a policy that enforces it and
the last one is encourage user to use
safe clients when they use when they use
Gmail so as Nico showed you we make a
tremendous effort in making sure that we
sanitize the content that we present you
in our email clients whether that's the
web client or Android or iOS so take
advantage of that you're the email the
your users email usage is gonna be much
safer if they use these clients than if
they use a third party client and last
but not least as we've seen in the locky
example the best security can be
defeated by exploiting human weaknesses
so educate your users to use email
responsibly avoid risky behaviors and
pay attention to all the signals and the
warnings that we provide to make sure
that your organization stay safe
[Music]
you